I've never been a captain before I hope  one day I could be a captain of your  dreams  best wishes Doug  [Applause]  [Music]  sorry mighty shut up God you want to go  happened to Doug Glatt it looks like  he's in pain on his right side looks  like a beautiful tiny mushroom person oh  cool how baby the Highlanders have  traded four star forward Anders candid I  attained now you can protect my team  those are you trained me and you know  what go teach me to fight it man left  how many turns up to tell ya just a  laugh  [Music]  what  let's Super Mario duck flatback is a  Highlander here we go  super thirsty  I don't want to anyone fight anymore  copa mu what am I looking at I'm Chad  Bailey you're watching sports desk  Sports Desk we're all pink on the inside  oh Jesus  [Music]  you